James Rymer the oldest Redwing is making
his first home appearance huge stops and
a shut out in Columbus was shirot but no
harm done there Lin brings it in with a
little room now and he got closed on by
weager back in front for Raymond moving
in comes Hall Hall's got it looks to the
middle scorers the break act who [Music]
else with his young son Archie well it was
almost a broken play but Hall alertly goes
back of the net and somehow this Puck finds
a way through the Goen back of the net bra
using his body strong back to the line for
hall for shat found a lane [Applause] scars
sherat from the blue line on a feet from
Hall who's got two assists and chat's got
his second goal you're right by Ben sherat wow
what did beleno tip it let's see maybe [Music]
y yeah it's feno well he's
on fire too got two go in
Ottawa that one off his leg and it looked like
it did Brink goes back for cider across for gosp
that's deflected but picked up by De Brink when
he tied to go in the period there's a shot save
rebound oh and that got blocked on the way through
the first one not the second one but boy prevented
the third one a save there from weager Mick and
the next save is the best yeah let's see to bring
Bret on the short side there's another look at the
right hand off of weager that Puck's going in the
net the brink it right hand shot on the left side
and the goal tender out of position for sure and
uh boy oh boy I'm telling you the brink it is
as usual off the rebound to Brink It Gos Fair
again now for cider 18 to go in the period Larin
down low with it crossed by Pon there's a shot
thear got down on that one on gos to spare at the
right time to get the those chances and here is
the chance that blew it right into him it's goess
bear who's got that offensive mind working all the
time as the Red Wings won five straight something
they're trying to accomplish early this season
now as the Flames fired in the Red Wings
defend the goal to our left and that shot
goes high and wide from Michael backer back
to the line moving in halfway came Hall into
the slot again great shot the brinka just
missed on a nicely set up feed from Lin
the brink it again back of the net taken out by
Hanahan hanahan's been out there for 90 seconds
now on this ship for Calgary knock down by
Raymond sherat the shot was deflected in
by voleno for the Red Wing second goal gerat
got it again goes into the corner H Again by
Hanan Lin across now for to Franken back
across for lin SC my goodness are you
serious we have seen Dylan Lin score goals
from this position almost down near the goal
line long distance pass holy mackel that's the
way to pick the top corner and Lin practices
this every day those goalies go down on their
knees pper again with good work Mata back his
way Comer again looked out front need a lot
of time there's a shot and a chance for cop
the pace with which the Red Wings are playing
are playing is uh really responsible for the
the results that they're getting they are
really really working hard and using their
speed C wax at it by back then they score
M [Applause] Pani shot skate shot rebound
and uh perfect position for M upon nobody in
front of him back and forth back and forth
for the hit go the spare a couple of times and
finally the king of the Flames are able to tap
it into an empty net so Rhymer shut out goes
to the the way side comes into the corner now
for Dylan duay felt pressure from cider coming
didn't handle the puck cleanly then ahead for
Raymond along with Lin great feet AC clock SC
what a feed Lin to break it it's 4 to one well
there's the response I was referring to and
those two lead the National Hockey League in
points now Lin and de Brink gender has pretty
much got to play Lin and that's why when he
makes the pass at the last second what a great
pass by Raymond under the heel of the stick in
front of the skates and Alex to Brink it with
a tremendous staggered starts across the league
the redling puck drop that night will be 8:23
7:30 though will be on the air Red Wings Live
Nick you won't get home 11:30 or so that b
start like old time hockey scores oh a shot
from Sharon goic wow his first is a [Applause]
flame it's a knuckle ball it looked like he saw
it because he moved to his right blocker
up in the way I don't think it hit cider
stick but like he's looking like where is
it did not hit the stick it just a on it's a
waffle ball they might have to bring a tape for
Arie remember down the road right that's right
yeah yeah he's under two so yeah way smiling as
he came in today man he must have KN what was to
come [Applause] HCK got deflected a knock down for
voleno a goal in this game for beleno as three the
past two he's got it again and a save by ladar Ken
got through the game and texting with him today
he is in okay spirits and Ken get well soon get
behind the mic soon we all wish you all the best
see you here soon scores right off the draw wman
that's for Cal right there it's 5 to2 it doesn't
take long for Detroit to regain the three-goal
lead nice win there by Baron
after valeno was tossed
outy so three-goal lead restored look
at the Bret the brink it is in the shot
scar [Music] [Applause] [Music] Patrick I I
don't have the right angle from here yet but
Raymond makes another beautiful play watch watch
him pull it snap it over the Blocker in the top
of the net boy oh boy oh boy I don't know but
Archie may have to come to every game I guess de
creeper holy meckel
wow Raymond and Hall assisting Hall's got three
assists and he's plus four now that makes him
plus five as the fans count it down Red Wings
with a fifth straight [Applause] [Music] win